Hallo Ach, ihr habt mich die ganze Zeit nicht gehört
oder was? Ihr habt mich null gehört oder was? Ich rede mit euch schon seit 5 minuten.
Aber guckt mal, das ist doch wieder ein Beweis, wie beschissen Windows ist oder? Ich hab nichts
geändert, ich hab nichts ausgesteckt, ich hab nichts eingesteckt, ich hab einfach nur,
doch ich hab ein Update gemacht vorhin. Ich hab Windows Update gemacht. Warum stellt ein
Windows Update mein Default Audio um? Warum ist das so scheiße? Warum kann es sich Microsoft
erlauben, sich bei sowas absolut keine Mühe zu geben? Ok, dann werde ich nochmal alles erzählen,
was ich jetzt die letzten 5 minuten erzählt hab. Als erstes hab ich gesagt, ich hab vorhin was bei
mir daheim gefunden in der Kiste. Neuer Audio Treiber. Ne, ich hab Windows Update gemacht.
Also, blablabla. Ne, das hört sich an wie immer. Hat der vielleicht den Sound wieder umgestellt?
Also, ich hab vorhin bei mir in der Kiste sowas gefunden. Ich dachte mir so kritisch,
dass sie mir den Kram heutzutage so nennt. Das wär bestimmt heute anders benannt worden.
Dann hab ich ein paar andere Sachen dazu erzählt, die weiß ich jetzt aber nicht mehr. Ja,
dass man das wahrscheinlich heute noch braucht, weil heute auch immer noch VGA im Umlauf ist,
so für Oldschool-Beamer und sowas. Dann hab ich noch irgendwas erzählt über die
Aussprache von Amazon oder so, keine Ahnung. 108, Moment. Das hab ich gelesen. Das ist ja auch
gut so. Breakthrough ist ja auch absoluter Dreck mit den Maps, wie es jetzt ist und dem Punkteplacement.
128 Spieler ist halt noch viel, viel mehr Crap. Das Problem ist, dass dieser Spielmodus,
so wie jetzt, auch mit 64 Spielern nicht funktioniert. Das ist halt lächerlich. Aber ganz ehrlich,
das Spiel ist eh dead. Das wird auch nie alive sein wieder. Die haben vorhin eine
neue Skin angekündigt. Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, endlich ein neuer Skin. Da hab ich aber ganz schön
lange drauf gewartet. Jetzt werd ich wieder installieren. Und ich hab gesagt, heute kaufen
wir endlich mal richtig den Kram ein, den ich das letzte Mal immer nur gesagt hab,
dass ich den endlich mal einkaufen muss, weil es wird echt Zeit. Ich hab jetzt drei Streams
gemacht und wir haben nur geschwätzt oder zwei Streams und wir haben nur geschwätzt. Und ich
bin nicht dazu gekommen. Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich habe vorhin gesehen,
man bekommt aktuell, weil wir es ja letztens von meinen Access Points hatten, man bekommt aktuell
aus England einen relativ günstig, wenn man schnell ist beim Beaten. Und zwar bald endend. Der ist es
nicht. Der ist bisschen teuer. Man bekommt in drei Tagen einen aus England für 270 Euro ungefähr,
wenn da sonst keiner drauf bietet. Könnt ihr ja mal gucken. Nee, nee, nee, nicht aus Freedom
Kocona. Der hier. Also wer auch so ein Access Point guckt, kann ja gucken aus England. England
geht über diese eBay, über dieses eBay Shipping. Das dauert meistens fünf, sechs Tage oder so eine
Woche, dann ist es da. Und ihr bezahlt aktuell 150 Pfund und dann nochmal irgendwie, ja,
sagen wir nochmal 70 Pfund obendrauf. Also sprich 230, nee, 220 Pfund, 220 Pfund in Euro sind 260,
260 Euro. Das ist doch okay. Das ist in Ordnung. Natürlich nur, wenn das bei Mindestgebot rausgeht,
was wahrscheinlich nicht so sein wird. Also mehr als 300 Euro würde ich nicht bezahlen. Aber ich
habe gesehen, was bald abläuft. Also falls einer auch noch Bock auf richtig schnell einen Access
Point hat, gibt euch. Mal wegen dem Label-Champ und einem eigenen Projekt heran, das wäre die
beste Möglichkeit von einer Web-Anwendung einen Druck auf einen angeschlossenen Drucker zu
initiieren ohne irgendwelche Browser Druck zu haben. Nee, also mit JavaScript kannst du
es insofern vergessen, weil du müsstest ja irgendwie diesen Drucker über, über,
wie heißt dieses Netzwerk Druckprotokoll? Ehm, ehm, ehm, Epp. Das müsstest du über Epp machen,
das kannst du nicht. Das geht nicht, weil da müsstest du TCP-Sockets haben und TCP-Sockets
Zugriff hast du mit JavaScript nicht, deswegen kannst du das knicken, das heißt du brauchst
auf jeden Fall irgendein Backend was das macht und die einfachste Variante in dem Fall ist
natürlich, also du willst ja nicht über Windows den Kram adden, über die Windows Druckersuche,
aber du kannst irgendeinen Backend machen was IPP spricht, da gibt es für die meisten
Sprachen Libraries, sogar für.NET gibt es welche.
IPP, also wenn das ein Netzwerkdrucker ist, ich gehe mal davon aus, ich gehe mal davon
aus es ist ein Netzwerkdrucker, weil du willst die Daten zum Drucker bekommen, also wenn
das ein Netzwerkdrucker ist dann IPP, da gibt es wie gesagt.NET, da gibt es für alles,
da gibt es für Go Libraries, für Node, du kannst auch in Node.js, kannst du auch machen,
Node.js hat sogar eine relativ gute, habe ich gesehen, IPP Library, keine Ahnung, du musst
mal gucken welche, aber die scheint ganz gut zu porten, also die einfachste Variante wäre
in dem Fall denke ich irgendein mini Backend, sei es Go, sei es.NET, sei es Node und mit
einem AP Endpunkt nämlich Upload von einem Bild oder so und dann kannst du es per IPP
dahin schicken.
Oh ja, ich habe es mitbekommen, die haben die Eintracht empfangen in Frankfurt auf irgendeinem
Platz, ich weiß nicht, Fußball juckt mich absolut gar nicht und jetzt ist Unwetter,
es geht richtig ab, guckt euch das mal an, irgendwie brauchen wir eine Wetterkarte oder
so, passt mal ab in Hanau, nicht in Hanau auch, aber in Frankfurt, in Frankfurt ist
gerade richtig MonkaS angesagt, Unwetterwarnung, ok es ist mehr oder weniger schon drüber,
es ist mehr oder weniger schon drüber über Frankfurt, aber sag euch, da geht es ab gerade,
ja auf dem Römer, stimmt, die werden eigentlich immer auf dem Römer empfangen, aber ich
denke hier geht es richtig ab, gerade, ich bin ja in Hanau, das wisst ihr, manche wahrscheinlich
und in Hanau hat es gerade die letzte halbe Stunde so krass gewittert und gestürmt als
die Katze ist auf dem Sofa, die hat Panik gekriegt, was ist hier los, nix sie weg, MonkaShake,
ja, also hier unwettermäßig, wo wir gerade dabei sind, jetzt kann ich doch mal gucken,
ob es mal eine Wetterstation gecheckt hat, Sekunde Leute, Wetter, Wetter Station, was
sagt die Wetter Station, Wind, Regen, ok aktuell kein Regen mehr, aber zwischenzeitlich 2,3
mm pro Stunde, was bedeutet mm pro Stunde, was steht das mm, Niederschlag, oh das ist
5 Head Unit, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt, mm pro Stunde, das sind keine Millimeter
oder, das ist irgendwas, da müsste es ja die Öffnung genormt sein, wenn das Millimeter
sind, mm, wie rechnet man das aus, ein mittelstarker Regenschauer, ein mittelstarker Regenschauer
mittelhoch war das von 5 mm, also ich hatte 7 oder 8, ich glaube 7 mm hatte ich gerade
Regen mit meiner Wetterstation gemessen hier, 7,8, 8, sagen wir 8, 8 mm habe ich gerade
gemessen, 8 mm scheint mir ja relativ viel zu sein, also es ist zwischen, zwischen mittelstarker,
also ein starker Regenschauer war das, es war kein Starkregen, aber die Wetterstation
steht ja auch nicht komplett irgendwie weit weg von allen Gebäuden oder auf den Baum
oben drauf oder so, also das regnet wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen aufs Dach nebenbei, obwohl
es eigentlich nicht unter dem Dach steht, ja, also jetzt wird es zusammen auch was geben,
aber ich habe keine Ahnung, warum es mm pro Stunde ist, kann mir das, aha die Höhe,
1 Liter pro Quadratmeter und Stunde ergibt 1 mm Regenhöhemenge in einer Stunde, ach
so, alter das ist ja die absolute Pfeiferteinheit, Big, Biggest Brain brauchste dafür, 1 Liter
pro Quadratmeter, also sind 8 dann 8 Liter pro Quadratmeter, keine Ahnung, Liter pro
Quadratmeter könnte ich irgendwie mehr anfangen, aber man kann das ja umrechnen, das ist tatsächlich
interessant, das wusste ich nicht, ja, also das mit dem Drucker, also das mit dem Drucker
haben wir ja beantwortet, also wenn du was wissen willst, schieß los, hast du den Wasserkocher
schon gekauft, ne bestellen wir heute aber alles, Matheprüfung und wir sind gelaufen,
ich habe heute meinen Chef geschockt auf der Arbeit, ich hoffe mal er guckt jetzt nicht
zu gerade, man weiß ja nie, wir hatten monatliche Rücksprache und ich habe mich erst ein bisschen
ausgelassen, was mir auf den Keks geht und sonst wie was und dann habe ich zu ihm gesagt,
ja wir müssen uns auch mal wieder über mehr Geld unterhalten und dann hat er gemeint,
gut dass ich sitze, aber gut, da musste durch als Führungskraft, hauptsache eine Wetterstation
und das nicht wissen, ja als kaufst du dir irgendwas und weißt alles im Detail, sobald
du es hast durch irgendwelche Eingebungen, ja ganz bestimmt, Inflation dies das, das
lassen sie bestimmt nicht gelten, weil im Prinzip es ist egal wann du fragst, dein Arbeitgeber
sagt immer so, oh jetzt ist ganz schlecht, jetzt ist gerade eine ungünstige Gelegenheit,
aber dann jedes Jahr erzählen nach dem Motto, wir haben ein neues Rekord ja, wir sind die
allergeilsten, ah aber jetzt ist schlecht, Corona ist schlecht, jetzt ist was anderes
schlecht, ah man, also irgendwelche Tipps um an einen Raspberry Pi zu kommen, also ich
habe meine letzten Barberry Base gekauft, da hatten die noch kurzzeitig welche, ich habe
Raspberry Pi 4s gekauft mit 8G für, ich weiß nicht mehr 120 Euro oder ne, 8G ne mit Netzteil
120 Euro, ihr wisst wir haben es zusammen im Stream gekauft, die Sache ist bloß die,
dass wahrscheinlich auch Barberry Base aktuell keine Raspberry Pi's hat, vermute ich jetzt,
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, derzeit nicht lieferbar ja, haben die sowas wie sofort lieferbar,
das Netzteil ist lieferbar, nice, nice, das wichtig, wichtig, wichtig, ganz ganz wichtig,
Leute ich muss mal nebenbei hören ob mein 3D Drucker fertig ist, dass ich den dann ausschalten
kann, ich druck nämlich gerade ein, ich druck kein Nanoleaf, dass ich schwachsinn, ich druck
mir gerade ein Shell, Shelf Mount oder so, keine Ahnung wie das eigentlich genau heißt,
ein Winkel für ein Regal oder für eine Holzplatte an der Wand, keine Ahnung nach was ich suchen
muss, what, nicht Self, Shelf, Shelf Alter, kein Planer, zumindest ich druck mir gerade
so, naja nicht sowas aber so ein Winkel, sowas hier in der Richtung druck ich mir gerade
aus und das braucht ungefähr eine Stunde pro, ja hier Winkel und ich will den dann ausmachen
weil der 3D Drucker da ist immer so laut und der macht hier ganz viel Feinstaub, mein Ikea
Sensor ist schon wieder auf Mittel, Raspberry Pi 2GB, nee gibt nix, aber seriously das
einzige was lieferbar ist, ist wirklich, guck mal ich hab gesagt sofort lieferbar und was
zeigt ihr mir an ein Raspberry Pi der nicht lieferbar ist, ja das ist ja richtig pfeifert
die Seite, welchen 3D Drucker hast du, ich hab ein I3 Mega S seit ein paar Jahren schon,
würde ich jetzt nicht mehr kaufen, also nicht weil er schlecht ist, sondern weil es mittlerweile
bessere gibt, noch bessere Einsteiger Drucker, aber der war ziemlich nice und ist auch noch
eigentlich ganz nice, einzig was bei dem dumm ist und das ist heute glaube ich auch im Einsteiger
Bereich möglich, ist das der automatische Kalibrierung von der Platte und dem Druckkopf
und sowas hat, oder wie heißt das, Extruder, nee das heißt ja nicht Druckkopf, Nozzle,
die Nozzle ist es genau, nee nachdem ich es jetzt mal ordentlich eingestellt hab ist okay,
aber so Auto Leveling und Messen und so finde ich wirklich cool, hat der halt nicht, werde
ich auch nicht nachrüsten, so also die haben anscheinend wirklich keinerlei Raspberry Pies,
keine Chance, das an PoE hat, aber das gute bei mir ist, ich hab noch 3 Raspberry Pie,
äh stimmt nicht, zwei Raspberry Pie 4 im Fleer Case hier rumstehen, weil ich hab einen aus
dem Wohnzimmer letztens abgebaut, den brauch ich nicht mehr, da ist jetzt temporär erstmal
wieder der Odroid dran und dann kommt vielleicht bald was anderes, was wir heute kaufen und
dann hab ich noch einen Raspberry Pie 3, das sollte reichen für nächste Zeit, Raspberry
Pie Needs, wer los man, nö, ich verlos doch in der aktuellen Keilzeit, kein Raspberry
Pie, warum soll ich das denn machen, also ich bin ja manchmal blöd, aber so blöd, dass
ich Raspberry Pie in der Zeit aus den Händen geb, bin ich nicht, ne okay die haben keinen,
ja bei Berry Base hat man manchmal tatsächlich noch Glück, aber, schauen wir mal, ob irgendwo
irgendein Laden was hat, das halte ich für ein Gerücht, lagern beim Händler für 48
Euro, nutzt du ein Repetier Server, nö, ich hab da ein Octopie dran und der schickt das
dahin und dann die Onboard-Firmware, die das druckt, ah, der 3 habt ihr es gehört, Piep,
der 3D Drucker ist fertig, muss ich kurz warten, bis er abgekühlt ist, der Raspberry Pie Locator,
das ist quasi der Preis-Champ nur in nicht so hübsch oder wie, Berry Base, sag ich doch,
aber in Last Stock, guck mal seht ihr das, Last in Stock, die hatten alle zuletzt einen
im April, das ist ja krass, so und das hier ist Cheap Bait, angeblich, was ist denn das
jetzt schon wieder, angeblich 48 Euro, so und wo soll das sein, Cheap Baited, guck
mal hier, ab 48 Euro, wo, wo ist es, angeblich lagern ab 48 Euro, wo, wo, wo ist es, ich
seh hier nix, also, wo soll das sein, ja welche, welche Variante denn, alle Varianten anzeigen,
Cheap Baited, einfach, ah hier, 1G, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es den 4er in 1G gibt,
was ist denn da UVP von dem Ding, 30, ich mein 1GB reicht für 90% der Dinger, die
man machen will auf den Dingern aus, aber ganz ehrlich, ich find so der, der Sweet Spot
normalerweise ist bei 2 besser, besser bei 4GB, 8GB braucht man nicht, also mir fällt
ein, fällt euch was ein Chat, was, für was braucht man 8GB RAM auf dem Raspberry Pi,
also mir fällt kein wirklich sinnvolles Anwendungsgebiet ein, außer so komische, ja fast schon esoterische
Dinger, wie einen, einen Kubernetes Cluster daheim zu betreiben mit 3 Raspberry Pis und
ganz vielen Containern und so, aber das macht ja keiner, ok Minecraft, ja, ja gut, wer Minecraft
auf dem Raspberry Pi hostet, vielleicht, also, fällt mir grad, äh, fällt mir nix zu ein,
1G ist auch irgendwie, ist nicht auch blöd, aber der Kram ist wirklich extrem teuer, also
ich hatte Glück, ich hab bei Berry Base das Ding für, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, 120
Euro, wir haben das Flir Case, den Raspberry Pi und das Netzteil bekommt für 120 Euro,
das war, das war ok, ja, da kannst du dir nicht beschweren, äh, haben wir gerade, ja,
Reserif, da ist er wieder, oder eigentlich ist es wahrscheinlich Preserif, weil Schriftart,
äh, danke für den Sub, ne, also keine Tipps, es gibt grad keine, keine Scheiße, äh, was
das, keine, manchmal, wenn das, manchmal hab ich das Problem, ich rede schneller als
ich nachdenke im Kopf, äh, keine Chance, nicht keine Scheiße, na Scheiße ist es, ja,
aber, sehr, das ist ne, das ist ne gute Anwendung für, für den ESP32, ja, ja, kann man machen.
Klopapier hab ich genug, ich hab mir zu Anfang von Corona eine Palette Klopapier bestellt
und damals haben die Leute auf Twitter gesagt, ich such das jetzt nicht raus, damals haben
die Leute auf Twitter gesagt, Max, du bist Teil des Problems, wie kannst du es nur wagen
dir Klopapier zu bestellen, da hab ich mir gedacht, wisst ihr was, mir vollkommen egal
was ihr da schreibt, ich hab wenigstens was, womit ich meine Arsch abputzen kann auch
in Zukunft, aber, das ist Twitter, Twitter empornt, emporrt sich permanent über alles
mögliche, mal ganz davon abgesehen, es war ja nie knapp das Klopapier, die haben einfach
nicht das Klopapier schnell genug zum Sommermarkt bekommen, das war ja das Hauptproblem, also
wenn ich bei irgendeinem Großhandel Palette Klopapier bestell, war das damals sogar besser,
weil ich hab den ganzen Supermarkt-Krams entlastet.
Wieso nimmst du eigentlich immer die Eins am Ende der Uhr weg, das liegt daran, ich
hab's erklärt, aber ich sag's noch mal ganz kurz, das liegt daran, weil ich mir irgendwann
abangeböhnt hab, immer eine Eins zu Copypasten, damit ich weiß, was ich im Clipboard habe,
ist das mein Tweet von damals, also Leute, wie findet ihr solche Tweets, ich find meine
eigenen Tweets nicht, dann finden Leute Tweets von 2020, wo ich Klopapier bestellt hab,
mit Ehre meets genommen, okay, der Typ hat wahrscheinlich rumgeflamet, egal, Twitter
von dir und dann Klopapier, exzellent, ja und ich möchte immer im Clipboard das dazu
erklären, also ich möchte immer wissen, was ich im Clipboard habe, das kommt aus Zeiten,
wo ich noch viel ICQ und andere Instant-Messenger und Ingame-Chat und sowas verwendet hab und
mir ist es dort manchmal passiert, dass ich Leuten ungeschickte Sachen geschrieben hab,
weil ich falsch Copypastet hab und seitdem will ich immer wissen, was ich in meinem Clipboard
hab, deswegen Copypaste ich die Eins.
Das hab ich mir so angewöhnt, das passiert schon ganz automatisch.
Warum trendet Armbrust auf Twitter, weil irgendein Typ, das hab ich vorhin in der Nachricht
gesehen, weil irgendein Typ mit der Armbrust an irgendeine Schule gegangen ist, ich glaub
war eine Schule und dort irgendeine Frau angeschossen oder sogar er schossen hat, bin mir jetzt
gar nicht sicher, irgendein Typ hat mit einer Armbrust auf Leute geschossen, deswegen trendet
wahrscheinlich Armbrust auf Twitter gerade.
Ich kenn Windows V, ich kenn das, man darf auch nicht abgeschaltet ab, weil ich sonst
irgendwas leake hier im Stream, aber ich möchte im Clipboard die Eins haben, das hab ich mir
so angewöhnt.
So und jetzt gehen wir mal, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, nein den Profikok wollen wir nicht,
den Profikok, so zu hier, weg, also was hab ich denn noch im Card drinnen, also Wetterstation,
die kann ich eigentlich löschen, den nehm ich auch ja, die kann ich löschen, weil die
hab ich mir schon bestellt, die hat mir übrigens der Chat empfohlen, was äußerst Fiveheader
war, weil die funktioniert ganz gut, ich lass jetzt so mal drin, dass man sieht, was ich
da alles bestellt hab, weil das ist ja öfters mal Thema, was man im Stream verwendet hat
an Hardware und so, kann ich das zeigen, so, also Wasserkocher brauch ich und ich brauch
noch einen neuen elektrischen, äh nicht elektrischen, nur weil das Electronics steht, das ist der
Hersteller iElectronics, äh einen Rauchmelder fürs Wohnzimmer und zwar einen mit Funk, deswegen
ist der auch so teuer, das ist mit 10 Jahres Funkmodul und 10 Jahres Akku, deswegen so einen
teuren und davon hab ich die anderen auch schon, die sind auch alle vernetzt und ich
hab eine Basisstation, die mir dann sogar Notifikation schickt, wenn es klingelt, exzellent.
Das ist der Fiveheadtime, ich bin nicht der Einziger, der das Problem hat, womit fängst
du die Signale auf, ich fange die Signale, das kann ich dir zeigen, archive, pass auf,
archive.wupplos.tv, woz, rauch, feuer, feuer, rauch, melder, ach ich hab den Stream gelöscht,
der Stream ist nicht mehr da, das war der Stream, wo ich so oft klacken musste zwischendurch,
den wollte ich nicht oben haben, äh ich empfange das mit iElectronics 403 oder so heißt das
denn, RF, RF, RF 603 oder so, nee, RF 602, ah man, wie heißt der Kram nochmal, Produkte,
Rauchwarnmelder, ja genau, Funkstation, das da, IF413, RF ist das Funkmodul, das ist
die Station mit der ich das empfange, so und das funktioniert folgendermaßen, nur mal ganz
schnell angemerkt, weil die das auch bauen wollen, also da, das ist nicht das was ich
brauche, ich brauch die Anleitung, äh genau, wenn du das Ding aufschaltest, hast du da
ein ziemlich minimalistisch bestücktes Panel drinnen, also so Board, hier schließt du
Input an, 11-30 Volt zur Stromversorgung, ähm und hier kannst du dann, an die Relays
kannst du irgendwelche GPIOs anschließen, irgendwelche Kontakte von einem ESP32 zum
Beispiel, ich hab einen ESP82, ich hab einen D1 Mini in der Box, passt, also da ist massig
Platz drinne hier, ne, also das Ding ist zum größten Teil leer, ich hab da einen ESP
2866 reingemacht und hab die GPIOs mit den Relays verbunden, also sprich mit, äh was
ist das, common, heißt das glaube ich, äh und dann normally open, hab ich das verbunden,
also das da oben ist Blödsinn, ja, hab ich die GPIOs verbunden, einmal für Fehler und
einmal für Brandmelder, weil CO2 Relays hab ich, also CO2 hab ich nicht, CO2 Melder und
dementsprechend bekomm ich jetzt den Input am GPIO, also das Ding, wenn Alarm ist, das
koppelst du halt auch mit den Funkrauchmeldern und wenn Alarm ist, dann schalt das Relay
und dann bekommst du ein Signal an GPIO und dann weißt du, wenn es der eine GPIO ist,
dann ist es ein Fehler, Fehler bedeutet in der Regel einfach die Batterie geht leer
und Brand bekommst du GPIO Input, wenn das Ding den Alarm auslöst und du kannst theoretisch
auch noch einen GPIO benutzen, ich hab einen ESP 2866, ich hab so einen dran, das liegt
aber auch daran, weil ich da von meiner, quasi meine Tüte gekauft hab, 5 Euro Aliexpress,
TASMOTA geflasht, GPIOs, TASMOTA geflasht, GPIOs da drin konfiguriert, fertig, total
easy gewesen, kriegst du hin, bin ich mir sicher, das ist nicht schwierig, du kannst
auch, wenn man das will, ich wollte das nicht, du kannst auch den GPIO Output schalten an
diesen Switch und dann kannst du quasi von deinem Raspberry Pi die Rauchmelder auslösen,
manche Leute verwenden das als Alarmanlage, also wenn die erkennen, dass das Fenster geöffnet
wird, obwohl keiner daheim ist oder sowas, dann machen die damit Alarm, aber das, das
finde ich blödsinnig, also kann man machen, würde ich aber nicht unbedingt empfehlen,
ist nicht, finde ich nicht so, finde ich nicht so, ja, also deswegen habe ich den Rauchmelder
reingemacht, so und jetzt, ich habe euch ja letztens gefragt, chat, was ich mir kaufen
sollte und zwar, es geht mir immer noch um Fernsehempfang drüben fürs Wohnzimmer und
ich habe euch gefragt, ob ich mir eine, ob ich mir so eine Box kaufen soll, wie gesagt,
Fernsehempfang, es geht nur um Empfang und streamen, Fernseh gucken werde ich weiter
über Kodi auf meinem Shield TV, das bleibt, es geht mir bloß um das Empfangen, das Recorden
und das Streamen, so und ich habe den Chat gefragt, ob ich mir so ein Ding kaufen soll
für DVBC oder ob ich mir eine Kabel Fritzbox kaufen soll, Kabel, oder ob ich mir eine Kabel
Fritzbox kaufen soll, also preislich nimmt sich das gar nicht mal so viel, die Fritzbox
kann ich noch anderweitig gebrauchen, weil ich habe aktuell das Unity Media Modem für
die Einwahl, ich nenne das mal Einwahl, auch wenn das bei Kabel nicht so ganz trifft, das
Unity Media Modem für die Einwahl und dahinter habe ich noch eine Fritzbox, die macht Deck
und Voip und Sachen, wer guckt Fernseh, ich nicht, meine Mutter guckt Fernseh, deswegen
muss der Kram auch funktionieren, so dass ich nicht supporten muss, ich will das hinstellen
und das soll einfach gehen, ich habe keinen Bock, dass es dann abends heißt Max guck mal
da Fernseh geht nicht oder so, das muss nicht sein, das soll einfach funktionieren, bin
für die Fritzbox, ich weiß das nicht, die Dinger sollen an sich rein für DVBC empfangen
sein, echt nicht schlecht sein, also was ich, der Vorteil sag mal so, Vorteil hiervon wäre,
ganz einfach, ich will nicht darüber gucken, also es ist egal ob es scheiß Upscaling hat
oder sonst, ich will einfach nur empfangen und aufnehmen, Vorteil hiervon wäre, ich hätte
einfach nur eine Box mit einem Linux drauf, da kann ich eine Festplatte rein machen oder
eine SSD, das hat hinten so ein Tray und ich hätte eine Box, die komplett alles macht,
Fernseh empfangen, Fernseh streamen, Fernseh aufnehmen, Aufnahmen planen, EPG übers Tablet
und was die nicht alles machen will und gut wäre, wenn ich den Kram über die Fritzbox
mache, bräuchte ich noch einen Raspberry Pi dabei, der die Aufnahmen macht, also da bräuchte
ich noch einen Raspberry Pi mit TV Headend, der dann die Tuner übers Netzwerk von der Fritzbox
verwendet, ich vermute, dass das prinzipiell mit der Box wahrscheinlich ein Ticken besser
funktioniert, Octagon, ja ich weiß, es gibt zig Sachen, es gibt zig Sachen und mein,
oder meinst du die Software, so und es gibt einen weiteren Vorteil Chat, wenn ich mir
diese Box kaufe, dann können wir die zusammen im Stream einrichten, was ich noch nicht so
ganz gecheckt habe ist, es gibt ja da auch irgendwie 30 verschiedene Firmwares, du hast
Open VT, nee, du hast Team VTI oder wie das heißt, das ist quasi die proprietäre Software
vom Hersteller mit ein bisschen Community Addons oder sowas, dann hast du Open AVT oder sowas
in der Richtung, das ist deutlich moderner vom Linux Unterbau, moderner Kernel, moderner
Libraries, hat aber ein paar proprietäre Sachen für die Tuner nicht, weiß nicht,
ob das schlimm ist und dann gibt es auch Open PLV und Black Hole Open und es gibt für dieses
Ding irgendwie 30 verschiedene Firmwares, ich habe keine Ahnung, was die Vorteile davon
sind. Ob VTL beste Wahl ist, weiß ich nicht, ich habe beispielsweise gelesen, dass wenn
man dort versucht, was drauf laufen zu lassen auf dem Linux, also wenn man da sich per SSH
darauf verbindet und dort versucht, irgendwas auch nur annähernd modernes Linux technisch
drauf laufen zu lassen, dann kannst du es vergessen, weil VTI uralt ist, also wenn ich
beispielsweise auf die Idee kommen sollte, irgendwas selbst zu programmieren, was darauf
laufen soll, ich meine, das ist glaube ich in AVM V7 oder so da drin, das geht ja prinzipiell,
aber die Libraries sind halt abfuck alt und du kannst nichts drauf laufen lassen und ich
bezweifle, dass VTI Docker Support hat, ich weiß es nicht, das müsste man ausprobieren,
deswegen bin ich geneigt, läuft auf dem Ding Go garantiert, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass darauf Go läuft. Das ist ein vollwertiges Linux, wenn auch
mit einer uralt Kernel, zumindest in VTI, mit Open AVT oder wie das heißt, ist das wohl
besser, nein, Open source, da Lico ist ja nicht open, sondern da ist open source und damit
kannst du ziemlich sicher Go drauf laufen lassen, ich meine Go läuft rückwärts kompatibel
bis zur Kernel 2.6.32 oder so und der ist von 2000, keine Ahnung, 5, Open ATV, ja, so,
chat, dann probieren wir das mal aus, ich brauche aber die mit DVBC, Samstag ist es
da, exellent, 5 header time, exquisite, macht euch nichts draus, ihr wisst, ich laber manchmal
sinnloses Zeug vor mich hin, so, also BAM, add, ist das das Richtige, was ich habe, DVBC,
was ist da ein FBC, FBC, die tun ihren Dienst schon ganz gut, hast du was, was den Dienst
noch besser tut oder meinst du, das ist halt, ist brauchbar, man braucht eigentlich nichts
anderes, was ist ein FBC Tuner, was ist das, dieser Tuner Typ ist erstmalig in einer Vo
S-Tipp, also das sind alles böhmische Dörfer für mich, was die hier schreiben, Full Band
Capture, dass das komplette Frequenzband einer Ebene empfangen wird, ich muss es nochmal
kurz betonen, ich hasse analoge oldschool Fernsehtechnik, da kommst du dir vor wie
im letzten Jahrtausend, wenn ich sowas schon lese, dann habe ich schon wieder gar keinen
Bock auf den Kram, so, also, wir machen jetzt gar nicht, ja das wird digital übertragen,
unter der Haube ist das immer noch wie analoges Fernseh, so, gut dann kaufen wir das jetzt,
also 299 Euro, ist ordentliches Ding oder, ich mein, kannst du nix sagen für ne Box,
die im Endeffekt einfach noch Fernseh aufnimmt, 40 Sender gleichzeitig rekorden, ja genau,
das brauch ich, weil so viel geiles Zeug im Fernseh läuft, also, add, bam, ich hoffe
ich hab jetzt das Richtige, ach so, was ist dann eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen
einer VU plus Duo und einer VU plus, außer, dass sie 100 Euro mehr kostet, nochmal, Moment,
VU plus Comparison, die Leute sitzen im C++ Gremium, Duo hat zwei Tuner, aber wozu brauche
ich zwei Tuner, wenn ich mit einem Tuner schon 40 Sender gleichzeitig empfangen kann, also
eigentlich komplett umsonst oder, so, Uno, Duo, ah hier, ok, der hat mehr CPU, mehr RAM,
nicht dass man es wirklich brauchen würde, oder, Zata, beide, Kartenleser brauch ich
nicht, Common Interface brauch ich auch nicht, CI plus Zertifizienz davon garantiert gar
nix, Netzwerk, alles das gleiche, Wi-Fi, brauch ich, das Ding hat Wi-Fi, wer braucht
denn Wi-Fi bei sowas, useless, braucht man nicht, CPU und RAM ist zum Streamen von HDTV,
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Streamen jetzt top funktioniert mit 3GB RAM
und mit 2GB RAM gar nicht, und dass du CPUs brauchst, das ist doch eh alles Hardware-Decode,
obwohl du musst ja nicht mal was decoden, decoden macht ja letztendlich der Klein, das funktioniert
auf jeden Fall auch so, würd mich ganz stark wundern, wenn das nicht geht.
Also es ist eigentlich kein großer Unterschied, ah, guck mal hier, HD-Dual-Transcoding und
die Uno hat nur HD-Transcode, ich will nix transcoden, ne, reicht, also ich geb jetzt,
ich mein 394 Euro, ich bitte euch, also für irgendein Streaming-Box, das muss so wirklich
nicht sein, also, so, hab ich's jetzt schon geadded, ne, Mist, toll, das hab ich zugemacht,
nice, GG Eats, ich will nix transcoden, gut, add Basket, und wisst ihr was, ich mach jetzt
den YOLO-Modus, weil, nicht einfach nur weil ich Geld ausgebe, Moment, ich seh Kundenleute,
ich muss mal kurz nach meinen Stonks gucken, du schaust die ganze Zeit bei No Longer Available,
was?
Hä?
Wo?
Egal, ich muss mal kurz nach meinen Stonks gucken, die sind wahrscheinlich heute wieder
gefallen, könnt ich mir vorstellen, ich hab ohne SE geschaut, ah ne, Moment, Moment,
Moment, Moment, das muss weg, das muss weg, will schon das aktuelle haben, ne, ist doch
richtig, ach du meinst in der Vergleichstabelle, hier, ne, SE, HD-Transcoding, das ist gleiche,
behindert sich nix, so, was machen die Stonks, heute, today, minus, 91 Euro, top, jetzt sagt
mir der Chat wahrscheinlich gleich wieder, Max, wenn der so weit, dann kauf doch jetzt
nach, alles klar, alter, ich hab die letzten, ich hab den letzten Monat, halt euch mal fest,
ich hab den letzten Monat minus 1639 Euro bei meinen Stonks, aber der Chat hat recht,
richtig minus ist es ja erst, wenn ich's verkaufe, not Stonks aktuell, eindeutig not Stonks.
Okay, weiter, in Wald investieren, ja, vielleicht in irgendwas investieren, was aktuell nicht
fällt, Amazon ist auch richtig krass am abkacken, die letzter Zeit, Amazon ist jetzt auch von
3000 Euro auf 2000, das ist halt echt, not Stonks alles aktuell, aber was willst du machen,
ich denke, das geht wieder aufwärts und dann ist es irgendwann auch ein Plus, top, ich
hätte eine Frage, die grad zusammenhanglos ist, ich wollte mal fragen, welche Unterschiede
die Affinity-Foto-Version aus dem Amazon, ich habe keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich ist
die Shop-Version kacke und die Download-Version besser, das würde sich mit anderen Erfahrungen
gemacht haben aus dem Store decken, gut, ja, wo ich gerade dabei war, Leute, ich werde
jetzt den Big Brain Move machen und mir auch noch eine Fritzbox kaufen, weil, nicht einfach
nur weil ich Geld ausgeben will oder hier den aus dem Weg Geringverdiener Weirdflex
starten will im Stream, nein, das liegt daran, es gibt keine Kabel-Fritzbox ohne Tuner, oder?
Ne, die haben alle Tuner, gehe ich mal von aus und ich will eigentlich das Unity-Media-Modem
rausschmeißen und ich möchte meine Billig-Fritzbox, die hat nämlich nur 100 MBit Netzwerk, was
nicht schlimm ist für VoIP und IP, also kein, kein, Voice-Over-IP, eigentlich kein Problem,
ich wollte eigentlich meine Billig-Fritzbox und die Unity-Media-Box durch ein Gerät ersetzen
und da wäre eine Kabel-Fritzbox tatsächlich ganz praktisch, dann kannst du auch erstmal
den Fritzbox-Tuner probieren, ne, ich kaufe beides, easy, die Frage ist nur, Fritzbox
Comparison, was denn da jetzt sinniger ist zu kaufen, gab es sicher Kabel-Modem, was
wirklich ein Modem ist, doch, gibt es ein paar, will ich aber nicht, weil dann habe ich ja
noch ein echt, also dann würde ich das Unity-Media-Gerät durch ein weiteres Gerät tauschen, aber
da hätte ich ein weiteres Gerät dahinter, ja, und jetzt kommen wieder irgendwelche Leute
an, die ganzen Low-IQ, ähm, ja, so, Halbwissen-Admins, die kommen dann um die Ecke und sagen,
aber Max, doppeltes Nut, ganz, ganz schlimm, doppeltes Nut und da kann ich einfach nur
sagen, diese Leute lecken ganz massiv Critical-Information, aber ganz massiv, das erste ist, unter Triple-Nut,
das ist so wie Julien-Spam, Dreifach-Faktor-Authentifizierung, ist es eh nicht sicher, und Spaß beiseite,
also, erstens, Carrier-Create-Nut ist wieder was anderes, mit Carrier-Create-Nut ist es
dann Triple-Nut, so, aber doppeltes Nut, erstens ist doppeltes Nut nicht wirklich schlimm,
auch wenn alle so tun, das ist nur unglücklich, wenn du Ports weiterleiten willst, oder in
seltenen Fällen, wenn du irgendwelche Traversal-Probleme hast, ja, mit, mit, ähm, VoIP-Geschichten,
die Löcher ins Nut machen wollen und so, aber meistens das klappt, also, in der Regel
ist doppeltes Nut kein Problem, wenn einfaches Nut auch kein Problem ist, so, das nächste
ist, nur, weil man eine Fritzbox hat und dahinter noch einen weiteren Router, muss man kein
doppeltes Nut machen, es ist sogar relativ bescheuert, doppeltes Nut zu machen, ich zeige
euch nochmal kurz das Bild von meinem Netzwerk, also, ich hab hier ein Mikrotik-Router, Sekunde,
ich hab hier ein, haben wir denn eh was Grelleres, Pink oder so, ich hab hier ein Mikrotik-Router,
ja, und dieser Mikrotik-Router ist hinter einer Unity-Media-Connectbox, die Unity-Media-Connectbox
macht Nut nach außen, was sie ja machen muss, weil, ich hab nur eine Public-IP-Adresse,
ich hab glücklicherweise einen richtig echten Dual-Stack, aber, das Ding hier macht Nut,
wie kommen die Leute drauf, dass dieses Gerät hier auch Nut machen muss, es gibt absolut
keinen Grund dafür, dass dieses Gerät auch Nut machen muss, warum sollte es, das ist
ein Router, ein Router kann routen, der muss nicht zwangsläufig Nut machen, du musst halt
gucken, dass seine Routen richtig gesetzt sind, ein Router, genau, aber du musst da
kein Nut machen, das einzige, was du machen musst ist, wenn du eine Route, also wenn du
eine Rückroute einrichten musst, dann musst du hier eine statische Route hinterlegen, dass
das hier dann der Gateway ist, für diese Route, aber das war's, könntest du den Mikrotik
auch die Einwahl machen lassen, ne, der kann PPoE, aber der kann nicht Kabelgedöns-Gramm,
das ist ein bisschen laut oder, besser, ja so sieht's aus, also es gibt keinen Grund,
dass man an der Stelle hier nochmal Nut machen müsste, weil vom Desktop hier, das hier ist
alles ohne Nut erreichbar, überhaupt gar kein Problem, das einzige, wo man aufpassen
muss ist, wenn man hier nicht nuttet, dass wenn man beispielsweise von dem Desktop auf
die Fritzbox zugreifen möchte, dann brauchst du hier eine Route, dass der weiß, wie er
zurückkommt, also dann reicht das hier nicht, dann muss es hier eine Rückroute geben, der
eben sagt, das ist der Gateway für dieses Netz, aber ansonsten brauchst du nicht, nur
weil du zwei Router hintereinander hast, doppeltes Nut, das ist nicht das gleiche, also deswegen,
die Leute lacken da ganz massiv critical information, was doppeltes Nut und Netzwerk Setups angeht,
ja gegen Carrier Create Nut kannst du eh nichts machen, da hast du eh keine Chance,
weil es heißt nicht umsonst Carrier, jaja könnte ich auch machen, mit der neuen Fritzbox
geht das, hast du dir Bock irgendwann mal eine PS5 oder Xbox Series X zu holen, wenn
ja, also ne hab ich nicht, weil ich hab mir zu Release die Xbox One und die PS4 gekauft
und ich hatte beides die komplette Lebensdauer dieser Konsolengeneration quasi nicht benutzt,
die waren insgesamt keine Ahnung 10 Stunden an oder so in ein paar Jahren, das war komplett
useless und ich sehe auch aktuell keinen Grund, warum ich mir eine PS5 oder Xbox Series X
holen soll, was ich mir holen werde ist, sollte es mal möglich sein demnächst eine neue NVIDIA
Grafikkartengeneration käuflich zu erwerben und eine neue CPU Generation, dann werde ich
das machen, weil mein Rechner ist jetzt, ja keine Ahnung, viereinhalb Jahre oder so, viel
zu alt, leider immer noch gut genug und deswegen wird es mal Zeit für neuen Rechner, 1080Ti
870K beste, 8700K, nicht 870K, weißt du ob man WireGuard oder OpenVPN durch Carrier
Crate Nut tunneln kann, ja du kannst prinzipiell alles durch alles tunneln, wenn du weißt wie
es geht, was nicht geht, ist Portweiterleitungen machen, Portweiterleitungen gehen insofern
nicht, weil beim Carrier Crate Nut ja auf der Seite quasi von Vodafone nochmal ein Nut
davor ist, da teilst du dir mit mehreren Leuten einen IPv4 Ausgang, so damit du dich quasi
dass du Port weiterleiten könntest, würde bedeuten Unity Media müsst ihr Zugriff auf
ihren Router geben, was sie bestimmt machen, chat gehe ich von aus, dass du dort eine Portweiterleitung
Einsätze einrichten kannst, also das kannst du knicken, also das kannst du knicken, aber
was du machen kannst ist, du brauchst einen Public Endpunkt im Internet, zum Beispiel
einen Hetzner Server, normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen Ausrufezeichen, Hetzner für
20€, Startkutschein, was auch immer, gibt es dieses Jahr bis jetzt noch nicht, du brauchst
einen Endpunkt im Internet und da tunnelt du dich drauf oder dahin machst du eine Verbindung
von innen nach außen und dann sagst du ihm, alles was dort reinkommt, leitest du weiter
da drüber über diesen Tunnel, das geht, da brauchst du aber einen Endpunkt im Internet,
es gibt noch viele andere Methoden, es gibt fertige Anbieter, die bieten dir irgendwelche
IPv4 in IPv6 Tunnel und sowas an, du brauchst keinen SSL Tunnel, das beste, also das einfachste,
das mit Abstand einfachste, was du machen kannst ist ein SSH Tunnel mit globaler Portweiterleitung,
SSH-G, das ist nicht das performanteste, weil SSH ist nicht dafür gedacht, keine Ahnung,
20 MB die Sekunde oder so zu tunneln, das verbraucht ganz schön viel CPU-Last, aber
man zum Prinzipiel testen, ob es geht, ist ein SSH Tunnel mit Minus-G am besten, also
sprich, Pfeifett-Time, jetzt lernen wir was, Chat, muss man mal kurz die VM anschmeißen,
dass wir was lernen können, Lern-Champ, Prüfungsrelevant, Chat, morgen wird es abgefragt,
SSL Tunnel ist verschlüsselt, SSH ist auch verschlüsselt, das einfachste ist SSH Tunnel,
wenn man einfach nur ausprobieren will, ob es funktioniert, so, stellt euch mal vor,
ich mach das jetzt auf Local-Host, aber das ist egal, wo ihr das macht, also stellt euch
mal vor, ihr habt einen Server mit Public-IP im Internet, dieser Server hat die IP Local-Host,
ich brauch was Lokales zum testen, das könnte genauso gut 1.5.4.3 oder so Public-IP sein,
das ist egal, so, also, SSH sollte ich vielleicht mal starten, CMCTL, Start, SSHD, so, das ist
ein, ach, das ist gar nicht Max, oder ist es Max? Okay, also, ihr habt einen Remote-Server,
damit ihr euch das besser vorstellen könnt, ich trag das in die Hosts ein, so, also, ähm,
Local-Host, ich hab noch einen Remote-Server, was weiß ich, Hetzner-Server, also, ihr habt
einen Server im Internet, SSH, MaxEd, Hetzner-Server, Leak, oh nein, ich wollte einkaufen, das muss
jetzt aber sein, das ist wichtig, also, ihr habt einen Hetzner-Server im Internet, darüber
wollt ihr jetzt, sagen wir mal, Port 600 oder 6.000, ihr wollt Port 6.000 weiterleiten an
einen, oder was ist WireGuard, WireGuard-Port, was ist das für ein Port, man, oh, UDP ist
schlecht, kann man das auf TCP machen, oh, das ist schlecht, okay, das funktioniert nicht,
ähm, UDP weiterleiten, klappt nicht gescheit, da geht VPN, ich hab auch immer OpenVPN gemacht,
dann nehmen wir mal das Beispiel OpenVPN, Beispiel OpenVPN, OpenVPN-Port, was, 443, ich nehm
jetzt das da, ist egal, also, wir gehen davon aus, Port 1194, also, ihr habt einen Public-Web-Server
und ihr wollt jetzt, dass euer VPN-Server aus dem Internet erreichbar ist, damit ihr
eine Verbindung aufbauen könnt zu eurem internen Netzwerk, also, das braucht man, weil man
beispielsweise nicht über das Carrier Create NAT von Vodafone von außen per Port-Weiterleitung
an euren VPN-Server kommt, so, und ihr habt jetzt einen Public-Server im Internet, Hetzner-Server,
und ihr wollt Port 1194 weiterleiten zu eurem VPN-Server, das heißt, ähm, also, ich hab
lange Zeit ein Open-Port-PN über TCP verwendet, das war kein Problem, ja, ich verstehe, ich
gette den Point, dass es besser ist über UDP, aber mit SSH-Weiterleitung funktioniert
es mit UDP nicht gescheit, also, ihr könnt jetzt einfach sagen, SSH, ich möchte diesen
Port weiterleiten, und zwar, ihr müsst sagen, SSH, Remote, ähm, und dann den, oh, warte,
warte mal, mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt aus dem Kopf, Sekunde-Chat, mal gucken, ob ich
das jetzt aus dem Kopf hinbekomme, äh, Remote-Port-Weiterleitung, Local-Port-Weiterleitung,
Local-Port-Weiterleitung, ihr wollt Local-Port-Weiterleitung, ihr wollt Local-Port-Weiterleitung, 119,
nee, nein, nein, ihr wollt Remote, Schwachsinn, ihr wollt Remote, Remote-Port, ihr wollt
Remote-Port 1194-Weiterleitung auf interne IP von euer VPN, euer interner VPN-Server,
also hier kommt die IP von eurem internen VPN-Server rein, so, und jetzt wollt ihr noch
sagen, minus G, so, und was das jetzt macht, ist folgendes, das baut eine Verbindung auf
zu eurem Hetzner-Server, öffnet dort Port 1194 global, also bindet es nicht nur an Localhost,
sondern bildet es als Interface, sodass es dann quasi auch über die Public-IP vom Hetzner-Server
erreichbar ist, alles was in Port 1194-TCP reingeht, wird über die VPN-Verbindung geschickt,
äh, über die SSH-Verbindung, und wenn es aus eurer SSH-Verbindung auf eurer Seite
rauskommt, dann schickt es euer SSH-Lokal weiter an die IP von eurem VPN-Server auf
Port 1194, so, und damit habt ihr extern zu eurem VPN-Server getunnet, sofern das OpenVPN
ist und sofern das über TCP ist, UDP funktioniert nicht gescheit, ich kann euch das auch zeigen,
netstat, ich hoffe ich hab die passenden Optionen dafür drinnen, ihr seht jetzt, wir haben
global Port 1194, nee, haben wir nicht, wir haben es nur auf Localhost, warum, dann muss
man es per SSH-Config, dann muss man es in der SSH-Config, ähm, aktivieren, dass man
Minus G verwenden kann, das kann sein, dass so standardmäßig nicht aktiviert ist, aber
Minus G ist das richtige Flag für Minus G, allow remote host to connect to local forwarded
host, bla, bla, bla, bla, also ihr müsst Minus G machen, dass er sich am kompletten Interface
bindet, das ist definitiv, das hab ich schon oft gemacht, das ist der richtige Befehl,
äh ja, ByteStrike, glaubt ihr, das ergibt schon Sinn, was du gesagt hast, ja, aber SSH-Port,
aber SSH-Tunnel ist das einfachste, was du machen kannst, und das geht nur gescheit
über TCP, zum testen ist das wunderbar, da kannst du nämlich ausprobieren, ob es überhaupt
funktioniert, so, und wenn du es dann ein bisschen, ein bisschen advanceder machen willst,
dass der Tunnel auch neu aufgebaut wird, wenn der mal abkackt, dann machst du noch Auto-SSH
davor, aber, äh, zum testen ist das wunderbar, wenn du einfach nur testen willst, geht das
denn prinzipiell von außen zu meinem VPN-Server, ansonsten, danach kannst du dir andere Tunnel-Techniken
überlegen, aber das ist mit Abstand das einfachste, wenn du einen Public-Server hast, um den zu
deinem, ähm, zu deinem VPN, internen VPN-Server zu bekommen, einfach zum ausprobieren, und
das ist prinzipiell was, was ich mir merken würde, weil man kann mit dieser SSH-Geschichte
unglaublich viel Scheiße anstellen, unglaublich viel Zeug umgehen, ähm, was man, was stört,
es gibt zigtausend Varianten, was du machen kannst, aber SSH-Tunnel ist in der Regel
das einfachste.
Ähm, wie kann ein Netz-Encrypt-Zertifikat im lokalen Netzwerk nutzen, zum Beispiel für
einen internen Webserver, geht das, ja das geht, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, dazu
brauchst du ein paar Sachen, eigentlich wollte ich einkaufen, aber wir haben ja noch, wir
haben ja noch 50 Minuten Zeit, also, dazu brauchst du ein paar Sachen, du brauchst eine
gültige Domain, das ist ganz wichtig, sonst funktioniert das nicht, du brauchst eine
echte, richtig registrierte Domain, das ist aber nicht schlimm, weil sowas kostet nix,
ja, suchen wir jetzt zum Beispiel mal nach QtChat und gucken uns mal, was die billigste
QtChat-Domain ist, QtChat.inc, guck mal, QtChat.yz, 95 Cent das Jahr, QtChat.inc ist lustigerweise
relativ teuer, QtChat.art ist auch nice, also es gibt sehr viele Domains, die sind sportbillig,
du brauchst zwingend eine Public Domain dafür, anders geht das nicht, das heißt nicht, dass
du einen Public Server dahinterstehen brauchst, du brauchst eine Domain, die es gibt, die
registriert ist und dann brauchst du einen DNS-Server, der dafür zuständig ist, den du per API steuern
kannst.
Ich empfehle dir Cloudflare, weil Cloudflare kostet nix und Cloudflare kann alles, was
man braucht und Cloudflare wird von so ziemlich jedem Let's Encrypt Client out of the box
unterstützt.
So, dann registrierst du dir einen Domain, stellst bei deinem Domain-Registrer ein, dass
Cloudflare für den DNS zuständig ist und das war's und dann sagst du deinem Let's Encrypt
Client zum Beispiel Certbot, dass du Let's Encrypt über DNS-Challenge verwenden willst
und zwar mit Cloudflare, dann musst du noch deinen Cloudflare API Key irgendwo hinterlegen
und dann geht der Certbot zu Let's Encrypt und sagt, du möchtest QtChat.io dir ein Zertifikat
ausstellen und dann sagt Let's Encrypt, ja, mach ich, du musst aber beweisen, dass dir
die Domain gehört, dann geht Certbot über deine Cloudflare API an den Cloudflare DNS,
hinterlegt dort ein Secret TXT-Rekord im DNS, ein Secret, was Certbot und Let's Encrypt
ausgemacht hat, hinterlegt dort ein Secret und dadurch, dass dann quasi dem DNS von
deiner Domain das Secret drin steht, was du mit Let's Encrypt quasi ausgetauscht hast,
beweist du Let's Encrypt damit, dass du der rechtmäßige Eigentümer der Domain bist und
du bekommst ein Zertifikat, das reicht, also du brauchst keine öffentlich auflösbare
Webserver oder sowas dafür, dann kriegst du ein Zertifikat und dann musst du einfach
nur lokal dafür sorgen, dass dein lokaler DNS eben einen A-Rekord hat für die Domain,
für die du dir das Zertifikat ausgestellt hast und dort dann auch ein Webserver läuft
mit diesem Zertifikat, ja, so sieht es aus.
Es gibt zig Varianten das zu machen, ach guck mal, tatsächlich, wir haben das sogar, du
kannst dir auch einfach das Wort angucken, da machen wir das irgendwann mal, aber mit
ganz viel komischem Docker Zeug dabei noch, ja, nice, das ist wieder was gelernt heute,
danke für die ganzen Zaps, ich hab wieder die Hälfte überlesen, tut mir leid, overlay,
extra für dich jetzt, Achtung, weeps in, Leute, weeps in, was wird eingekauft, endlich mal
den ganzen Krempel der noch aussteht, äh, was ist das, äh, nicht zwangsläufig, der
Domain Registral ist dort wo du hingehst und sagst ich möchte, möchte diese Domain kaufen,
er ist prinzipiell auch erstmal zuständig für den DNS, aber, du kannst sagen, dass
du, ähm, also, nee, der DNS Registral ist immer zuständig für deine Domain und auch
der DNS vom Domain Registral, aber du kannst dort einstellen, dass der DNS, der letztendlich
die Records auflöst für deine Domain, dass das ein anderer DNS ist, also sprich, dann
sagt dein, ähm, Domain Registral DNS, wenn einer nach dem Namen fragt, hey, ähm, ich
bin zwar für diese Domain zuständig, aber auflösen kann die ein anderer DNS und dann
geht der nach Cloudflare und macht deine Namensauflösung, oder besser gesagt, TXT Records für Let's
Encrypt.
Wozu macht man das, wenn man nicht einfach sein eigenes Zertifikat erstellen kann, das
ist eine gute Frage, erste mal, rein Security-technisch, so von Verschlüsselung oder Nicht-Verschlüsselung,
macht es erstmal wenig Unterschied, ob man ein Self-Sign Zertifikat hat oder ein Let's
Encrypt Zertifikat, also die Verschlüsselung ist dadurch weder besser noch schlechter,
der einzige und zwar riesengroße, nicht zu unterschätzende Unterschied ist, dass dein
Browser Let's Encrypt Zertifikaten vertraut und selbst ausgestellten Zertifikaten nicht,
das heißt, wenn du sowas hier haben willst in deiner Browser-Leiste, dann musst du entweder
deine CA importieren im Browser und das auf jedem Rechner, der dann selbst sein Zertifikat
verwenden soll, oder du verwendest Let's Encrypt, dem jeder Browser schon standardmäßig vertraut.
Also, das ist halt deutlich praktischer.
Übrigens, Fun-Fact von der Arbeit, mal was zum Kekken, wir haben es letztens geschafft
an das Let's Encrypt Zertifikatslimit zu kommen und wisst ihr warum, weil irgendwelche Leute
Kubernetes Sachen deployed haben und auf einmal haltet euch fest 88, nein ich will euch jetzt
auch nichts verstecktes mitteilen damit, weil bei dieser Zahl kommen immer irgendwelche
Leute an, ha ha, tut mir übrigens leid für alle die 88 geboren sind, weil irgendein komisches
Kubernetes Deployment bei uns dafür gesorgt hat, dass 88 Let's Encrypt Anfragen geschickt
wurden für neue Zertifikate, die haben nicht etwa gesagt Renew Request oder Refresh, nein
die wollten neue Zertifikate anfordern, warum auch immer und dann hat Let's Encrypt gesagt
Nope, für diese Woche gibt es keine neuen Zertifikate mehr und das fuckt die Leute bei
uns gerade ziemlich ab, weil die auch legitime Anwendungsgründe haben sich Zertifikate auszustellen,
aber Let's Encrypt, du kannst bei Let's Encrypt ein Formular ausfüllen, dass du deine Limits
erhöht haben willst oder so, aber die Plösse will sich da keiner geben und das würden die
wahrscheinlich auch nicht machen und jetzt können wir uns eine Woche lang keine Let's
Encrypt Zertifikate ausstellen, wie gesagt Renews sind nicht betroffen, deswegen ist
das ganze halb so wild.
Nö, nicht wirklich, YouTube Werbeeinnahmen ist genauso wie Twitch Werbeeinnahmen, also
YouTube Werbeeinnahmen sind deutlich besser als Twitch Werbeeinnahmen, aber Lohnen kann
man dazu nicht sagen, also wenn du normal guckst ist das auch vollkommen ausreichend,
ich hab auch gegen niemanden was der Erdblocker anschaltet oder so, die Werbeeinnahmen sind
ganz ok, aber wenn ich, wenn ich, ich verdiene damit ja schon passiv bisschen Kohle nebenbei,
also mit YouTube und auch mit den Twitch Subscriptions und sowas, aber wenn ich Stonks machen will,
dann mach ich irgendwelche Promotion Geschichten, das gibt deutlich mehr, hab ich aber aktuell
nix und ich bin eigentlich ganz glücklich so wie das ist, ich brauch nicht zwangsläufig
jetzt mehr Geld einfach nur um Geld zu machen, also meine Stonks könnten bisschen besser
laufen.
Doch, machen wir wahrscheinlich auch jetzt, wahrscheinlich kaufen sie sich jetzt auch
ein Zertifikat, aber das klappt an manchen Stellen nicht gescheit, weil sie eben darauf
setzen das Auto-Renew mit Let's Encrypt funktioniert und das mit Auto-Renew und Zertifizierung
stellen, dann musst du das wieder umstellen, vielleicht warten sie auch ne Woche, so ok
weiter geht's, also wir haben meinen Receiver und ich wollt mir, ich wollt die Fritzbox
kommen, boah, boah, Leute Sekunde, oh, meine Augen, warum geht das nicht, alter, geht es
hier, oh, yes, ok, ich weiß nicht warum es mein Dark Reader da nicht kann, aber, so also
was ist der Unterschied, also wir wollen Cable haben, Cable Fritzbox gibt's nur drei oder
kommt da noch was, ne, Jibay, der sieht nur so aus, Leute, ich glaube hier hat's einer
bei AVM das nicht so drauf mit First und Last CSS Elementen, man könnte das viel schicker
machen mit diesen Strichen hier neben, dass es nicht so aussieht als käme da noch was,
sag ich ja als absoluter Five Head CSS Frontend Full Stack bis Sek DevOps Engineer, ich muss
das wissen, so was ist denn jetzt der Unterschied zwischen diesen ganzen Dingern, Wi-Fi 6, 5
plus 4, ja 5 plus 4 ist doch eindeutig besser als 6 oder, weiß gar nicht warum das die
günstigere ist, muss man nicht verstehen, Papa, nicht dass jetzt jemand um die Ecke
kommt und sagt, Bugs, 6 ist doch viel besser, außerdem sind wir Informatikos, die haben
kein 6, ok, Wi-Fi 6 vielleicht, so, also da haben sie Multiuse, ich brauche ich nicht
weil kein Wi-Fi, Dual Band Wi-Fi, brauche ich Honored, das interessiert mich alles überhaupt
nicht, ich weiß, ich weiß, die Witze sind heute äußerst Payne's Champ, ich geb's zu,
ich geb's zu, Leute, ich muss euch mal was wirklich cool fand erzählen, und zwar ihr
wisst ja, ich hab jetzt mittlerweile um die 9 Kilo abgenommen und ich war am Dienstag
auf der Arbeit und da hab ich einen Kollege gesehen, den hab ich schon eine Weile nicht
mehr gesehen und das erste was der gesagt hat ist, Max, du hast abgenommen, das fand
ich nicht schlecht, da sieht man, dass man's auch wirklich sieht, oh nee, das ist richtig
nice, ja, das motiviert natürlich, das hat mich so sehr motiviert, Leute, dass ich das
letzte Mal war, ich war noch, keine Ahnung, Dienstag war das, direkt nachdem ich, abends
nachdem ich, abends nachdem ich von der Arbeit gekommen bin, das hat mich so sehr motiviert,
dass ich beim eineinhalb Stunden, zwei Stunden täglich durch die Wiese bergdings wandern
mit einem Fahrradgrill, ich nenn's mal, geflirtet habe, stell euch das mal vor, Alter, da muss
ich schon hart motiviert sein, dass ich mich auf irgendwelche zwischenmenschliche Gespräche
einlasse und das auch noch freiwillig, Sachen gibt's, hätt ich mir vor ein paar Jahren
auch noch nicht vorstellen können, dass ich freiwillig mit Leuten kommuniziere, ja, mit
einem Fahrradgrill, genau, einem hocken Fahrradgrill mit Sonnenbrille auf, sehr motiviert, dass
man erstmal ein fettes Eis essen geht, ja, ich geh tatsächlich ab und zu Eis essen, manchmal
muss das sein, so, weiter, ich wollt mir die Fritz-Boxens angucken, so, WiFi zu euch interessiert
mir, also, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, macht es überhaupt keinen Sinn für mich,
die teure Fritz-Box zu kaufen, ich kann einfach die günstigere Fritz-Box kaufen, 6660, warum
gibt es überhaupt noch, was ist denn das für eine Benamung, 6690, 6591, MonkaS, Alter,
diese Benamung wieder, man, haben die alle Quad-Tuner, sieht man das da, Tuner, da steht
überhaupt nichts von Tuner, aber die haben alle Quad-Tuner, oder, XQC hat sich umbenannt,
ja, der hieß ja XQC-OV, das würd mich nicht wundern, wenn der mal das OV bald aus dem
Namen streicht, wie heißt er denn jetzt, wahrscheinlich einfach nur XQC, oder, ja, ja, das wundert
mich nicht, gute Sicht über die verbauten CPUs und RAM, ok, zeig ich her, fritzboxinfo.com,
was es nicht alles gibt, boah, Alter, was ist das für eine Seite, man, Keg-Wade, was
ist das, seriously, Webdesign aus den 2000ern, Alter, so, 6600 Cable, Tuner, Tuner, stehen
da die Tuner drin, Anzahl, Tuner, hier, ne, das ist Fragezeichen, wie viele Tuner hat
die denn, das muss doch da drinne stehen irgendwo, Moment, Moment, Moment, Details, Details, Specs,
Tuner, Tuner, Pull-Band-Capture-Tuner, das ist doch, das ist doch genau so ein Ding, ok,
also kann ich auch ohne Probleme die billigere fritzbox kaufen, Specifications, Tuner, weil,
warum nicht, ja, warum, ich mein, ich muss ja nicht zwangsläufig mehr Geld ausgeben
als irgendwie notwendig, Amazon, was ist los, oh, Snap, ok, alles klar, ok, ok, ok, ok,
alles klar, Moment, das nimmt sich doch jetzt preislich gar nicht so, ach, die sind out
of stock, die ist gar nicht lieferbar, oder, ne, die ist nicht lieferbar, ne, die haben
beide vier Netzwerk-Ports, oder, die eine hat bloß ein 2,5G-Cable, die haben alle, ach,
ne, tatsächlich, ach, ja, tatsächlich, die hat ein Port, ja, was ist das denn, warum hat
die denn weniger, das muss man alles nicht verstehen, ne, naja, gut, ich, wisst ihr,
was ich nicht verstehe, warum hat Amazon nicht einfach was, wo man draufklicken kann, sagen,
so Sachen, die lieferbar sind, was soll das denn, ja, ok, komm, scheiß drauf, dann kaufe
ich halt die, jetzt ist Euro da, hoher Staffel ist lieferbar, heftiger Scan bei AVM in den
Fritzboxen, warum ist das Scam, was gegen deine eigene Fritzbox spricht, ja, ich hab wenig
Probleme in den letzten Jahren, aber das ist mir klar, dass die das sagen, das ist Standard-Bullshit
von Providern, das bin ich schon gewohnt, das ist normal, so, gut, jetzt haben wir das,
jetzt muss ich mal in meine Einkaufsliste kurz schauen, Geizhals, können wir tatsächlich
machen, das ist eine gute Idee, lieferbar, ok, das lohnt sich tatsächlich, e-Systems
Your Online Shop, oh, die haben aber richtig gute Bewertungen, Vorsicht, unseriöser Händler,
grauenhafter Kunde, gut, da werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht bestellen bei e-Systems Your Online
Store, ok, das ist natürlich preislich schon mal ein großer Unterschied, ok, das ist natürlich
eine gute Idee, ok, das lohnt sich tatsächlich, ok, das lohnt sich tatsächlich, ok, das ist
eine gute Idee, ok, das lohnt sich tatsächlich, ok, das lohnt sich tatsächlich, ok, das lohnt
Und das hat richtig gesagt
Massive gesagt hat das
Only one left in stock
Aja, ist das refurbished? Ach das ist used
Ach leck mir keinen bock, ich guck jetzt auf zu gucken. Wir schauen jetzt was anderes nach. Ah Amazon war wieder am abkacken alles klar nice
Okay
Next also was brauche ich denn sonst noch
Bei der usv bin ich immer wir können bei alt habe ich wirklich lange nicht mehr nix mehr gekauft ja
Und mit denen habe ich immer noch gute erfahrungen gemacht was alternate angeht
Und früher dachte ich die heißen alternate
Ich habe
also als ich noch klein war
Aber ich mittags bei der obach immer mittags bei der oma mittagessen und die hat die ganzen
Zeitungen für mich gesammelt weil da immer werbeheftchen drinne waren
Werbeheftchen von von alternate und und zeug und alles ich habe damals halt gerne diese die ganzen pc angebote und so mir angeguckt
Und
Da kam da habe ich mir zwei sachen
gemerkt und zwar einmal dass es alternate heißt weil das meine oma auch gesagt hat und
dass es nicht heißt sondern als er
Meine oma hat immer gesagt als er zu als er
So auf lagen aber hier kostet die die gar
Ja mittlerweile gibt es als das ist ein komischer router das ist ein komischer gaming router wo ich nicht verstehe warum man sich den kram kauft
Aber hat schon die pilling hat wo ich keine ahnung habe warum man sich sowas kauft
Das kann ich dir empfehlen ich will kein kabel modem was soll ich mit dem kabel modem
Ich will ja zwei kisten durch eine ersetzen wenn ich mir einen kabel modem kauf und dann habe ich wieder
Ein wieder zwei kisten da kann ich auch das unity media den mir behalten mir mir stehen lassen egal so nächstes also nächste sache
Zwar müssen wir ein bisschen vorwärts kommen ok
Lass mal kurz überlegen ich brauche ein ja da bin ich mir nicht sicher also
Vielleicht wisst ihr nach was ich da suchen muss ich ich finde ich ich finde ich finde ich find nix und zwar was ich aktuell habe
Ich habe im flur unten
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz ich habe nicht uk europe
Also ich habe eine livex wlan lampe unten im
Im flur die macht nicht nur rgb beleuchtung sondern die macht auch infrarot beleuchtung das ist die einzige wlan led von denen die das kann
Nightwish also ich die by the way der preis ist lächerlich bei denen ist es normalerweise deutlich günstiger
Alter was ist mit euch los also das kostet normalerweise 50 euro oder so ist trotzdem trotzdem zu teuer
So was so was hier
Also so die ist kaputt und die will ich auch nicht erneuern
Erstens weil ich die zu teuer finden und zweitens weil ich über die lebensdauer enttäuscht bin die hat es ungefähr nur
anderthalb jahre zwei jahre gemacht und
gerade rgb led lampen sollten deutlich deutlich länger halten der kram ist ja auch nicht irgendwie den ganzen tach an oder so
Also so was ich mir überlegt habe was ich mir kaufen könnte irgendeine infrarot beleuchtung
aber
Da finde ich dinge die für mich keinen sinn ergeben
Ich habe keine ahnung wie nach was ich suchen muss dass ich mir eine keine ahnung zwölf so was in der richtung will ich aber
halt vielleicht nicht billiger chinesen krab
Aber so was in der richtung will ich haben nach was muss ich da suchen ich habe keine ahnung wenn ich nach
eher beleuchtung eher lampe oder so suche da finde ich alles möglich also ich finde vielleicht
heizungsdinger oder so aber ich finde nix was ich quasi an ein netzteil anschließe und mir dann den flur nachts
ausleuchtet für nacht sicht
Und am besten hätte ich das ganze noch in einer wellenlänge
die
nicht
sichtbar ist
Ich werde jetzt sagen infrarot ist nie ist nie sichtbar das kann man so nicht sagen je nach wellenlänge
Erkennst du zumindest die leds dass die an sind
so was da
Ja also vielleicht vielleicht nicht zu so einem krassen preis oder
Das ist zu teuer 250 euro ich will den flur ein bisschen erleuchten
Wisst ihr was ich mir schon überlegt habe die led strahler ok
Wisst ihr was ich mir schon überlegt habe ob ich nicht einfach meine packung china chinesen leds nehme
und die auf einen
breadboard stecke und das auf den schrank lege mit irgendwie acht leds drauf oder so
Und das auf den schrank lege mit irgendwie acht leds drauf oder so
Danach habe ich auch schon gesucht da findet man nix gescheites
Was otto
Ach nee
london das ist
Das tonter das ist auch irgendein china chinesen ding
Ja was ist es denn jetzt
Ja moment moment moment
Was ist es denn jetzt ist es ein infrarot licht für nacht sicht oder ist es ein infrared heater
Ich meine mir ist klar dass alles in gewisser weise wärme verursacht in der richtung aber das primäre ziel soll sein
dass licht für nacht sicht in den flur kommt und nicht das heizen von irgendwas
Also das ist preislich was das würde ich mir gefallen lassen
Ja wenn die das finde ich halt auch blöd wenn die leds rot leuchten das heißt das bräuchte man auf irgendeiner wellenlänge
die nicht
Topics den du gesendet hast der kostet 250 euro
Ach nee das noch ein anderer
90 euro
Ach nee das ist noch ein anderer
Ja 90 euro ich meine das ist mir eigentlich ein bisschen viel für ein paar infrarot leds
Die frage ist welche wellenlänge sind die sieht man die nachts rot leuchten oder nicht
Und wo sind da überhaupt die leds dahinter
Es kommt doch bestimmt direkt aus china oder
drop shipping
China von China chinesen
Das speichert die leuchten
Das speichere ich mir mal vielleicht vielleicht hole ich das teil
Aber ich bin der sp echt bisschen planloser was ich suchen soll weiß nicht
So das nächste was ich brauche ist hat jetzt gar nichts mit technik zu tun ich brauche eine säge und zwar am liebsten so eine zum klappen
So das nächste was ich brauche ist hat jetzt gar nichts mit technik zu tun ich brauche eine säge
Und zwar am liebsten so eine zum klappen
Klappen, vielleicht nicht so was China-Chinesen billiges, sondern ich brauch ne Segel, irgendwas
kleines zum klappen, sowas da in der Richtung, nur von irgendeinem Hersteller, der mir was
sagt, denn sowas da zum Beispiel ja, was ich sägen will, Äste zum Beispiel, also ich
brauch, ich brauch, ich brauch ne Segel, sowas da, 28 Euro, Fein-Feed, Coarse-Feed, nicht
Feed, Teeth, warum sag ich Feed, Akku-Kettensäge, ich brauch keine Akku-Kettensäge, ich brauch
das für abgeschnittenes Zeug, was ich mal durchteilen muss, das was vielleicht minimal
zu dick für die Astschere ist, auch keine Akku-Kettensäge, außerdem hab ich ne Akku-Kettensäge,
ich brauch ne ganz normale kleine Klapp-Säge, keine Akku-Kettensäge, 28 Euro, perfekt,
will ich haben, Marken-Baumarkt 24, gib ihm, exzellent, Säge am Start, Leute wisst ihr
was ich letztens genannt hab, es gibt eine Amazon Basic USB, keine Sorge, ich will die
mir nicht kaufen, meint ihr das taugt was, ich hab nicht vor mir das zu kaufen, meint
ihr eine Amazon Basic USB taugt was, oder kann was taugen, Amazon Basic ist dafür bekannt,
Produkte die ganz gut sind zu kopieren, also quasi die legalen China-Chinesen, wenn du
es so willst, ich will mir nichts kaufen, also keine, ihr müsst euch nicht Gedanken
machen, dass demnächst abbrennt bei mir, aber ob sich das, dann schauen wir mal kurz
in die Bewertung, ich frag mich halt echt ob das irgendwas taugt, Eistings, Schrott sagt
er, wieder ein Teil aus China wahrscheinlich, das ist das was du brauchst Max, ok, Zack,
taugt mal her, was ist das, ja genau, ganz wichtig, wenn man Äste zersägen will, die
Dschungelmachete, wobei bei komischen Amazon-Dingern, da fällt mir immer nur dieses Meme-Taschenmesser
ein, Swiss Knife Meme, ich weiß nicht an was ich suchen soll, Taschenmesser für 900 Euro,
ja, ne, ne, das ist noch zu klein Leute, das ist noch zu klein, der Victorino Swiss Champ,
endlich mal einer der meine Benamung übernimmt, der Schweizer Champ ist das, gibt es dieses
Meme-Taschenmesser gar nicht mehr, doch hier, da ist es doch, da ist es doch, das Wenger
Swiss Giant Knife with Box, das meine ich, das ist ein mega krasses Teil, ich weiß nicht
wo das denn davon sein soll, sowas zu haben, mitnehmen kannst du es nicht wirklich, aber
ihr müsst euch mal die Kommentare durchgucken, im Prinzip sind, ist das alles, das gibt's
schon jahrelang dieses Produkt, im Prinzip machen sich die Kommentare alle darüber
lustig, 1,4 Kilo, bestes Taschenmesser Produkt ever, so, ähm, hast du eine USB, nein, doch,
doch, doch, das stimmt nicht, aber die geht nicht mehr, also ich hatte, früher hatte
ich so eine ganz normale APC Steckdosenleiste im Endeffekt, als ich meinen 19 Zoll Rack
hier hingestellt habe, habe ich mir gedacht, ok, ich kaufe auch mal einen Hersteller, wo
ich ein bisschen, den ich kenne und wo ich weiß, das taugt was, da habe ich mir eine
Cyber Power USB gekauft, aber die hat mich schwer enttäuscht, weil der das einzige Male
in der ganzen Zeit, wo mein komplettes Rack abgekackt ist, war nicht als bei einem Stromausfall,
sondern als die Power, Cyber Power USB verreckt ist, ja, das habe ich letztens mir auch was
angeguckt, aber ich bin immer noch hin und her gerissen, ob ich mir nicht die, die, die,
die günstige hier von Ethon, Ethon, wie die ausspricht, kaufen soll, sowas da, oder einfach
YOLO ohne USB, also wahrscheinlich YOLO ohne USB weiter, ja, Cyber Power ist kacke gewesen
bei mir, Yatong USB, oh ja, China-Chinesen-USB, das brauche ich, laufen die Dinger weiter,
wenn die Batterie abkackt, also wenn Strom da ist und die Batterie verreckt, geht es
da noch weiter, das ist die, das ist die Sache, weil bisher hatte ich nur Probleme, wenn die,
als die USB verreckt ist, nicht, dass da Strom ausgefallen ist, ne, keine Ref-Links, das
stimmt, muss nicht sein, ich meine, wisst ihr, was ich machen könnte, ohne Scheiß,
das mache ich, ich mache, ich kaufe das, was wir uns letztens angeguckt haben, was sind
eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen der Pro-Series und der Eco-Series, Comparison, wir Comparison,
Comparisieren heute relativ viel, ja, Online-USB mag zwar cooler klingen, somit keine Last-Spitzen
im Strom und sonst wie, also, ne, keine Spannungsspitzen und so, aber Online-USB ist halt der Sack,
dass wenn die Batterie verreckt und der Strom noch geht, dann ist trotzdem der Strom weg
für alle Server, Modelle, die Pro hat eine Webschnittstelle, das ist cool, aber ich will
halt unbedingt eine, die weiterläuft, wenn die Batterie verreckt, was ist denn das hier
für ein Vergleich, komm wieder, ok, schauen wir mal, was hier der Unterschied ist, die
günstigen APCs können das wahrscheinlich, weil sie nicht den Strom permanent durch den
Akku leiten, dann ist kein Ding, aber USBs, die ihren, was ist das, Chat, Chainlaw, was
hast du da neben dir für Dinger, was ist das, Batches, Watching without Video, wo ist der
Sinn davon, von Batches, ich mein, was interessiert es mich, ob der Chainlaw mit oder ohne, mit
Audio oder ohne Audio guckt, ah, ja, das ergibt Sinn, ok, das verstehe ich, das verstehe
ich, also sprich, jetzt fangen sie alle an, also sprich, wenn ich jetzt sehen würde,
dass ganz viele Leute ohne Audio watchen, weil sie hörgeschädigt sind, könnte ich
keine Ahnung, Text to Speech einpländen oder so, äh nee, Speech to Text einpländen, naja,
das macht aber wenigstens Sinn, verstehe, verstehe, ok, also, was war denn jetzt der
Unterschied, ihr sagtet, die haben ein Interface übers Netzwerk, nee, haben sie nicht, haben
auch USB, ja, dann weiß ich es nicht, versus Echo, hm, ist das eine Online-USB und das
andere Offline-USB, wahrscheinlich, ne, dann habe ich keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied
ist, die würden gut dran tun, das etwas prominenter zu platzieren, was der Unterschied ist, dann
könnte man sich nämlich einfacher dafür entscheiden, die hat kein Display, ich brauche
kein Display, Display juckt mich so gar nicht, das kommt auf die Art der USB an, also ja,
die meisten machen das und die wo der Strom quasi permanent gefiltert zu den Systemen
kommt, die machen das, aber wenn du was hast, der quasi nur umschaltet, wenn Stromausfall
ist, dann kommt es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen auf die Bauweise an, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung,
ich check nicht so genau, was sich das lohnt, ob es der Unterschied, ob sich das lohnt,
also ich bin geneigt dazu tatsächlich, einfach mal die kleinste hiervon mit USB zu kaufen,
Ö, Ö, Öko, was, Echo, komme ich auf Öko, so, mit USB, USB, so, ich bin geneigt das
Ding einfach mal zu kaufen, zum ausprobieren und wenn das nicht gescheit funktioniert oder
nicht das macht, wie ich mir das vorstelle, dann ich werde einfach mal die Batterie abstöpseln
und gucken, ob es weiter läuft und wenn das da nicht geht, dann schicke ich es zurück,
dafür ist Amazon ja bekannt, ja, dass sie da keine, keinen Stress machen, Amazon hat
bisher alles, Amazon hat sogar meine Reifen, die ich dort bestellt habe, wieder zurückgenommen,
irgendjemand hat gefragt, eine USB mit Interface, wofür braucht man dann sowas, sind Schoko
Stecker oder, das glaube ich nicht schlecht, das passt, da kann ich meine Leiste anschließen,
also wozu eine USB, ich finde es hier gar nicht, wozu braucht eine USB Interface, naja,
es ist ganz praktisch mitzubekommen, wenn die USB leer geht, um die Server runterzufahren,
ob das jetzt über Netzwerk geht oder über USB, ist eigentlich zweitrangig, über Netzwerk
wäre irgendwie cool gewesen, aber über USB geht genauso, haben die auch rackmounted,
oh, ok, die rackmounted Geschichten, da lecke ich critical information bisher, die will
ich nicht, die ist mir zu teuer, na gut, das ist aber auch ordentliches, heftiges Ding,
373 ist eigentlich immer noch zu krass, aber wäre noch im Bereich, die langen aber gut
zu, für die rackmounted Dinger, funktionieren die auch, wenn du den Akku abstöpselst im
laufenden Betrieb, hast du mal ausprobiert, Max, hol dir mal Kock, yep, dazu kann ich
euch was erzählen, es hat gestern ein Kollege, das passt jetzt wie die Faust aufs Auge zu
diesem Comment, gestern hat ein Kollege zufälligerweise sein Passwort geleakt auf der Arbeit und wisst
ihr, wie das Passwort war, Pimmelcock123, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das wirklich
geleakt hat oder ob das quasi ein Jebait-Leak war, aber es würde gut passen zu ihm, dass
er Pimmelcock123 als Passwort hat, insofern, ja, ich lache einfach mal, es war vielleicht
echt sein echtes Passwort, ich meine, das ist gar kein so schlechtes Passwort, wie viele
Stellen sind denn das, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, naja gut, es ist kein
richtig gutes Passwort, 13 Stellen sind eigentlich ticken zu wenig, aber immerhin, immerhin
13 Stellen, so, ok, ich habe noch 2 Minuten Zeit, was brauche ich denn noch, ich brauche
besonders dünne Netzwerkkabel immer noch, ach ja, wenn ich mir dieses Dinge bestelle,
wenn ich mir jetzt wirklich die Box zum Recorden bestelle, dann brauche ich noch eine SSD,
ich habe keine freie 2TB SSD mehr, wobei doch, was labere ich denn, natürlich habe ich noch,
ich habe nämlich hier, die habe ich doch noch da, da habe ich mir noch damals fürs Nass,
weil ich dumm war, 2 Stücke gekauft, die ich jetzt gar nicht verwende, einer ist aber
Raspberry Pi dran, ich meine die wird es ja auch per USB tun letztendlich, Fernsehaufnahmen,
na wobei, die die du gegen die Wand geworfen hast, stimmt, ich habe letztens eine SSD gegen
die Wand geworfen, welche war das denn, oh shit, das war eine 2TB SSD, die war aber im
Arsch, das war die BX, 500BX, BX, ja, das Teil habe ich letztens gegen die Wand gefeffert,
na ja, ich probiere es mal aus, die geht bestimmt noch, ganz ehrlich, SSDs sind so robust, die
überleben das, also da ist ja auch nichts abgebrochen oder rausgekriegt, die hat das
bestimmt überlebt, dass ich sie gegen die Wand gefeffert habe, die Cuvo wäre gar nicht
so doof, weil für Fernsehaufnahmen reicht es dicke und wie heißt dieser Speicher in
der Cuvo dieser, mit mehreren Zellen, der reicht ja eigentlich, PC, korrekt, so alt
ist mein PC, guckt euch das mal an, 2017, cringe, cringe, wer den Rechner von 2017
hat, kennst du das, ja das kenne ich, finde ich ist ein nice Gehäuse, falls das das ist,
mit diesem Zusatz-Anstecker, mit diesem Zusatz-Dock, ja genau, also was heißt Dock, mit dieser
zweiten Hälfte, die man so rein steckt, das hat sich jetzt falsch angehört, aber ja,
wenn man das Gehäuse von innen sieht, weiß man was ich meine, die zweite Hälfte, die
man auch noch rein steckt, so und das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool, wobei ich sagen
muss, ein bisschen teuer, wenn man halt eine M2 anschließt, ist das das mit M2 oder, ist
das das mit M2, ja, ist das halt cool, die Sache ist halt die, but why, also warum eine
M2 SSD über USB an den Raspberry Pi, ich habe keine Ahnung wo das Sinn ist, aber es
ist cool, dass es geht, ich verstehe den Sinn nicht so genau ehrlich gesagt.
Was für ein Recorder, der Chat hat gesagt, beste, VU plus beste, wir wissen der Chat
hat bei solchen Sachen noch nie unrecht gehabt, Chat erinnert ihr euch an einen, an auch nur
eine Voraussage, die ihr getroffen habt, die nicht eingetreten ist, also ich kann mich
nie dran erinnern, dass der Chat jemals falsch gelegen hat, gerade durch die vielen Prime
Subs und dieser wahnsinnige EQ Boost, die man bekommt dadurch, kann man eigentlich
kollektiv nicht falsch liegen, ich meine, wir haben gerade 224 Zuschauer, das sind 224
Zuschauer, wenn alle nur 150 EQ haben und was durch die Prime Subs mittlerweile überhaupt
kein Problem ist, da haben wir hier im Chat aktuell 33.600 EQ Punkte, also es ist eigentlich
nicht möglich, dass der Chat falsch liegt, das ist 6-Head schon nicht mehr ausreichend,
das ist eigentlich absolut 360-11-Head schon, bei dir soll ich 150 abziehen, das heißt
du hast Null?
Das kann nicht sein, allein schon, dass du am Rechner bist und weißt, wie der Chat bedient
wird, kannst du nicht Null haben, da hat der Chat tatsächlich Recht, aber nur weil der
Chat Recht hat, heißt es ja immer noch nicht, dass ich es am Ende auch mache, also ich
kaufe mir neue CPU und einen komplett neuen Rechner, letztendlich wird es wahrscheinlich
wieder ein Reboot von meinem alten Rechner, ich hör mir nämlich wieder an Fractal Design,
ja was ist denn das aktuelle, R7, ich hatte die letzten paar Rechner Generationen, die
ich hatte, hatten alle dieses Fractal Design R Dingsbums Define, immer wieder die neueste
Version und ich finde das Gehäuse so nice, das werde ich mir wahrscheinlich einfach wiederholen,
jetzt fragt vielleicht jemand, warum verwendest du denn nicht das alte Gehäuse wieder, wenn
ich es doch schon mehrere Rechner Generationen hatte, das ist ganz einfach, weil ich zu
faul bin, weil dann müsste ich den alten Rechner vom Dachboden holen, ausbauen oder den aktuellen
Rechner, der hier steht und dann zum nächsten Dachboden Rechner wird, ich schmeiße ja sowas
dann weg, äh ausbauen, da habe ich keinen Dock drauf, da bin ich zu faul, da gebe ich
lieber 120 Euro aus und kaufe ein neues Gehäuse, so aber sobald es wieder soweit ist, sobald
es wieder soweit ist, dass es eine neue Nvidia Grafikkarten Generation gibt, ey das ist doof,
das will ich nicht, dann kaufe ich mir einen neuen Rechner, am besten natürlich in Kombination
mit neuer CPU Generation, ich hätte mir ja gerne letztes Jahr schon oder vorletztes Jahr
schon immer endlich mal wieder ein AMD System gekauft, aber so wie es aktuell aussieht,
scheint ja Intel halbwegs aufgeschlossen zu haben und mal gucken wie die nächste Generation
aussieht, bin gespannt.
Max heute schon eine Eins kopiert, ich glaube wir bräuchten einen Counter, ich habe heute
wahrscheinlich schon 420 Einsen kopiert, wenn das mal reicht, warum ist der Airflow beschissen?
Hä, warum ist der Airflow beschissen?
Ich mein, der Airflow geht vorne rein mit Lüftern und direkt hinten über die CPU wieder
raus, also Moment, wo ist denn vorne die Tür offen, also, ich brauchte es mal ohne Tür
vorne, so, es ist ja schön, dass ihr 30 Milliarden Bilder habt von eurem Gehäuse, aber wie wäre
es denn mal von vorne mit geöffneter Tür, gibt es nicht, hier, so, du hast vorne den
Lüfter drin, du hast vorne den Lüfter drin und hinten den Lüfter, das geht, ach so,
du meinst, weil vorne zu ist, also du meinst, wenn es vorne offen wäre, wäre das besser
als dass er das nebenan saugen muss, ja gut, das ist wohl wahr, ja, das ist oben zu und
es hat vorne nur was zum ansaugen an der Seite, ja das schöne ist aber, dass das überall
Luftfilter und sowas hat, das wird nullstaubig, ok, das verstehe ich, dass vorne nicht so
viel reinkommt, aber ganz im Ernst, das ist komplett ausreichend, ich mein, wenn man
seine CPU jetzt irgendwie so am Limit übertaktet mit mehr Spannung und allem, ok, dann verstehe
ich es, aber mein Rechner läuft im Desktop-Pertrieb nahezu silent und ja, wenn ich Spiele anmache,
dreht er halt ein bisschen hoch, aber, vielleicht sollte ich mir aber wirklich ein neues Gehäuse
angucken für nächsten Build, Fractal, die sind Meshify 2, die Namen von Gehäusen werden
auch immer geiler, aber nix toppt, irgendwelche Mainboards, die KillerFatality, Headshot Pro
oder so heißen, ok, das sieht tatsächlich auch ganz schick aus, ist da, ist da das allerwichtigste,
Staubfilter, Fragezeichen, meint ihr Nvidia stellt dieses Jahr ihre 4000er Serie vor,
ich hoffe es, weil ansonsten kaufe ich mir keinen neuen Rechner, Moment, wir schauen
mal kurz, ob die auch wieder so ein, wie nennt sich das so, dieses Explode View heißt das
glaube ich, Explode Ansicht, da ist, ok, gut, da ist ein Luftfilter dabei, sowohl oben
als auch unten, ja, das ist cool, das gefällt mir, Cost, ja gut, das kostet ungefähr so
viel wie das Fractal Design, Define, Blah, R, irgendetwas, gut, aber oben, also oben wäre
es mir tatsächlich lieber, wenn das zu wäre, ich will, ich will gar nicht, dass das oben
auf ist, weil oben auf heißt auch mehr Krach kommt raus, hast du mitbekommen, dass Nvidia
teilweise ihre Linux Treiber open sourced, ja, soweit ich weiß, open sourced Nvidia
ihre Linux Treiber komplett, was sie nicht open sourcen ist ihre Compute Geschichte,
also CUDA und, wahrscheinlich irgendwelche NVN Geschichten und sonst was, aber der eigentliche
Grafikkartentreiber wird angeblich komplett open sourced, ja, kauf mir keine Wasserkühlung,
bin überhaupt kein Fan von Wasserkühlung, Wasserkühlung ist nicht, ist die Weis, abwarten
ist immer noch Nvidia, ja das stimmt wohl, also Gehäuse die oben zu sind finde ich persönlich
nett, weil ich habe die Gehäuse ja quasi so schräg neben mir stehen und ich bin äußerst
empfindlich was Rechnergeräuche angeht, also ich möchte, dass der im normalen Desktop
Betrieb wirklich silent ist, was, also silent heißt für mich nicht lüfterlos, sondern
halt, dass ich es nicht höre und ich habe aktuell einen Noctua DH15, kann das sein,
so ein Lüfter, wenn der hoch dreht, ich meine da geht es richtig ab, ja, ach guck mal mit
6 Heatpipes, wusste ich gar nicht, dass er 6 Heatpipes hat, ne ich hab nur, ich hab den
gleichen mit nur einem Lüfter anstatt 2, also wenn der richtig hoch dreht und über
seine 6 Heatpipes den Kram abtransportiert, dann wird es auch laut, aber im Desktop Betrieb
dreht er leise und ist richtig, richtig leise, ja, es mir gerade aufgefallen, dass ich aus
irgendwelchen Gründen mal ein sinnloses Text-to-Speech für Heatpipes eingebaut hab, ja, der ist top
der Lüfter, weiß nicht ob der immer noch angesagt ist, Kopfhörer, ne Kopfhörer ist
keine Alternative zu im Desktop Betrieb nicht hörbare Rechner, man hat zwar öfters Kopfhörer
auf, sei es, dass man mietet oder dass man was spielt oder so, aber ich sitz oft genug
vorm Rechner und hab absichtlich keine Kopfhörer auf, wenn man den ganzen Tag den Kopfhörer
auf hat ist es auch nicht angenehm und mir reicht das schon, ich muss so viele Stunden
mieten am Tag mittlerweile, wo ich Kopfhörer auf hab, da will ich auch so mal vorm Rechner
sitzen ohne Kopfhörer und deswegen muss das im Desktop Betrieb silent sein oder halt silent
bedeutet für mich ich hör ihn nicht und das ist aktuell so, ja das sind Österreicher,
doch Doktora sind Österreicher, jeder Kopfhörer ist bei 12 Stunden am Tag irgendwann zu viel,
außerdem kommt mir die Luft an die Ohren, sei denn man braucht das nicht, kannst du
mir die neue Xbox bauen, easy, kein Problem, haben wir, mit einem ESP32 drin, vor allem
bei den warmen, ja das schöne ist gerade, ich hab meine Klimaanlage vorgestern angeschaltet
und seitdem seh ich auf der Arbeit die Leute die ganze Zeit im Chat schreiben, boah heute
ist aber, geht aber hier richtig, richtig warm, denk ich mir so, was, Kegweight, bei
mir ist angenehm, 23, 24 Grad, aber ich häng das nicht so sehr an die große Glocke, weil
es 20 Meter weird flex, ja, so Leute, Bettke, ja 23, 24 Grad ist doch ok, was hast du für
eine Klimaanlage, ja das ist ein Splitgerät, ich hab eine Außenstation an der Wand und
mehrere Innendinger, das wusste ich mir auch von irgendeinem Kelte, Kelte, wie nennt sich
das, du brauchst eh ne gewisse Zertifizierung, dass du überhaupt Anlagen, Klimaanlagen einbauen
lassen kannst, Kelte, irgendein Handwerker der zertifiziert ist Klimaanlagen einzubauen,
bei denen hab ich das gemacht, Klimatechniker, Kältetechniker, das ist das was ich gemeint
hab, ja, die sind dann angerückt, haben ein Loch in die Wand gebohrt, mit nem Schlauch
durch und haben dann da das draußen angeschlossen, haben sie draußen auf die Leiter gestellt
und was mich damals überrascht hat ist, die hatten zwei Mädels dabei, also es waren zwei
Kerle und zwei Mädels, die die Klimaanlage eingebaut haben, hätt ich jetzt gar nicht
im Handwerkerbereich so vermutet, so ungefähr ja, also das Haus hat mal der Opa, ne der Opa
hat es auch nicht gebaut, das stimmt gar nicht, der, ich glaub mein Opa oder so hat
es gebaut, der der irgendwann nach Südafrika abgehauen ist, Baujahr ist irgendwie 1900
rum oder so, es ist also auch noch sehr massiv gebaut, zwei verschiedene Deckel, wenn es
den geschlossenen Deckel hat bin ich sofort dabei, Pog, so Leute, Bethke, gibt es irgendjemanden
den ich hausten kann, Semper Video hab ich das letzte Mal gehostet, Massive genau wie
Max, so ist es, so siehts aus, ich hab was mit nix zuerst gemacht, ne, man könnte, bin
ich jetzt quasi ein Achtel Afrikaner oder so, wobei das zählt ja nicht, mein Opa ist
ja nur abgehauen nach Südafrika, was damals viele gemacht haben, damals haben viele Frauen
und Kinder in Deutschland sitzen lassen und sind nach Südafrika, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht warum, bin ich historisch nicht so bewandert, äh bewandt, ey ich mag keine
Wasserkühlung, egal Leute, Bett geht time, ich geh jetzt schlafen, wir sehen uns vielleicht
morgen im nächsten Stream, mal gucken, paar Sachen muss ich noch einkaufen, vielleicht
mal morgen wirklich dann auch die ganzen Sachen komplett, weil alles, alles haben wir
heute nicht hinbekommen, aber wir waren schon relativ effektiv im Vergleich zu sonst, wie
krieg ich denn das wieder weg, und ich geh jetzt pennen, wir sehen uns, bis dahin, machts
gut, see you.